one of the activists heard in that video
is suing the city and challenging a
state law against standing too close to
cops in Indiana police can demand the
bystanders keep a 25-foot distance while
the cops performed their duties the
lawsuit says this violates the first
amendment by preventing citizens from
being able to record and observe police
activity the plaintiff runs the freedom
to film YouTube channel where he posts
footage of police activity around South
Bend so are cops allowed to stop you
from filming other states have tried
similar laws but they haven't passed
legal Master that's because citizens
have the right to film or observe cops
as long as they aren't actively
interfering with police
Indiana politicians say they want to
protect police from unnecessary
distractions but in reality they're
protecting police from necessary
scrutiny thank you